what's up everyone hello welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saucon now
we're sitting down with Leo Madrid
hello Thank You Man yeah thanks for
having me thank you I'm really excited
Leo's a consciousness researcher and
people evolve as consciousness expands
peace is the acronym yes they do yes
they do I love that acronym it's a good
one
and I love how you came so prepared with
all the stuff that you gave me too
that I really I should have been even
more well prepared on but this is very
expanding conscious and expanding itself
let's let's let's touch base on this so
maybe let's do a little bit about your
let's do a little bit about your
background first so Navy engineer 10
years yes okay cool I would say a 10
year Navy career roughly half of that
was hardcore engineering out on a ship
you know running the engineering plant
and very applied physics and and then
the second half there was a lot of
school in there too but then the second
half I was basically a like an
instructor and more on the
organizational development quality
management side of things and was
stationed at my last station was here in
a s Alameda oh cool yeah that's what
originally brought me to the Bay Area
was getting station and and I didn't
really have that big of a interest in
physics or engineering and in school and
I was really kind of an undirected kid
you know and didn't have a but but I
kind of had this fall back where nothing
great can it happen I could always join
the military and I had other people in
my family my father was in the in the
army grandfather was a flying tiger in
World War two and so there was a lot of
that was kind of an easy option for so I
didn't really pay a lot of attention in
school I didn't do that great and didn't
really have a lot of confidence in my
own intellectual ability you know I
really didn't see college as an option
and did not look attractive to me
neither did venturing out to the world
trying to get a job and doing something
I had no idea what my interests were and
so I was still a junior in high school
when I made the decision to join the
Navy but I did so well on the entrance
exam yeah that I can choose from
anything that's great and I was like wow
that's cool and I chose the absolute
hardest job the Navy had to offer which
was it's uh engineering and the
engineering working with the boilers and
the turbines yeah you know and and it
was it was quite an experience but when
I when I got to school I went to boot
camp really loved boot camp I really
excelled there and had some actual some
latent leadership abilities I wasn't
even aware of and that that came out
there and then I went on to engineering
school after boot camp and I loved it I
loved I was actually getting paid to
learn and I really just jumped into it
full-on and why a lot of the other guys
were out partying on the weekends I was
you know doing my studies and working
and and just getting it all done and it
was very competitive it was very
competitive like your grades were posted
every week you know so there was a
running competition and I was fortunate
enough to have a pretty well-rounded
approach to it and was one of the
youngest honor graduates in the history
of the school and it was just because I
went active duty six weeks after I was
18 but a lot of the people that were
there had full college degrees they were
nuclear engineers and and and I
graduated number one and so I was like
wow I'm great mark about ten years
working with boilers turbines yeah
teaching ten years of that and then the
entire time I was going to school part
time so if the ship was at sea for a
long enough period of time there'd
actually be college professors on board
or you could take classes and if the
ship was import long enough which was
pretty rare it only happened a couple
times but I would take a class yeah you
know so I was constantly working
full-time and basically learning
full-time outside of that
and so when I got stationed here my I
had one class to take and then I was
finished with my lower division credits
and I got accepted into an executive
management training program at st.
Mary's College here in the Bay Area and
so I wit that was a full-time load at
night and coincidental not not
coincidentally actually but I was the
Navy was sending me to graduate level
schools of the same management think so
I was literally going to school at night
and applying it the next day and vice
versa yeah it was a cycle so it was a
really intense learning session but it
paid off I graduated with the BA in
business pretty much the same time
within a couple of months of getting out
of the Navy so what does it really
entail to be living on a submarine well
I was on a ship I'm on a ship yeah yeah
God even if submarine would be just not
think but he was on a ship I know but a
submarine no it's actually sometimes
it's not that different because because
when you're you're an engineer I had
duties that required me to go topside
but if you're an engineer working in the
pit it's what they called an engineering
room you could literally go weeks and
weeks weeks out without even going
needing to go topside it's still good
damn son but when you've got you know
when you're if you've been awake for 24
hours 30 hours 50 hours you're going to
sleep so it's it's a very intense form
of living you know being at sea no
matter schipper sure and you guys had
like a thousand people on that ship
no my first ship had 300 people
it was a fast frigate hunting for
submarines Special Warfare helo ops that
kind of thing and then the second ship
was a guided missile cruiser 100 more
people hundred feet longer but something
there was I and I think actually this is
what this was the single experience but
on my first ship that led me to this
where I'm at today
and it was there's a there's a
qualification that that people can get
or at the tie no they still around I
don't know the specifics of it now but
it's called East was--and listed surface
warfare specialist and what it means is
you have an operational understanding of
every single system on the ship and
sometimes it takes you most people at
least when I was in most people didn't
have the qualification it was purely
optional and and but I was a real
go-getter you know I wanted to do
everything I possibly could and when I
got to the ship we had a few small
deployments and I learned about the East
wasp but there was there was a there was
a requirement you had to have two years
they've got two years of active duty or
two years at sea time I can't remember
but yeah I'd have two years and you had
to be an e5 that's in rank you know and
it goes from e 1 to e 9 so you had to be
e5 right in the middle and I was barely
new but because I was an honor graduate
and had some of the other stuff I had I
had advanced to eat for pretty quick but
I still didn't meet the requirements and
but I really wanted this and we were
getting ready to go out on the
deployment and so I put in a special
request to the captain to hey can I can
I go for this and every person that was
enlisted in my immediate chain of
command said no because they didn't have
the qualification was really I think
what it was but I didn't meet the
minimum requirements either and it goes
all the way up it gets to the captain
and I think my division officer said if
you if we allow you to go after this and
you don't do it it's going to reflect
very poor yeah yeah you know because
you're not yeah yeah and I was like
let's do it let's do this so the captain
signed yes and okay great I'm gonna do
it and but I basically had two years a
year and a half to do it you know wasn't
there was no time learning the
operations of every entire ship of the
entire ship and I buddied up with a guy
who was a little bit older than me a
little bit more seasons he kind of
mentored me we were both on the
firefighting teams because I was a
firefighting team leader as well
and and we decided to do it together
this is a really valuable lesson to me
it's kind of like one of the first
lessons in entrepreneurship that I've
read over to see the same thing over and
over again don't do it alone don't go
out it alone you know and this was a
great great lesson in that the the power
of teamwork in that he and I both
decided we're gonna we're gonna do this
together he was he didn't have to go any
through any special requests because he
had the rank and he had the time but we
decided we were gonna do it together and
we're gonna do it as fast as possible
you know and so we were getting ready to
go on my first big deployment was to the
Middle East to Gulf Persian Gulf and we
were our goal was to finish it on one
deployment do the entire thing and that
was a month or two months or six months
six months at sea six months away from
home yeah yeah the most time you
actually spend at sea is about three
months without seeing land and we decide
without seeing anything anything I mean
women and that's that's a that's a big
one yeah I do remember being at sea like
you do underway replenishment and
there's the replenishing ships had women
and look and it was it was a it was
interesting interesting time living with
like four hundred other men on the boat
okay so I mean the engineering and
knowing all the operations on the ship
is that's really important to know that
that's fascinating and do because
society is also very complex like that
yeah you can understand the operations
society as well they'll give you a great
a lot of interrelationships yeah
and with the with the I mean just the
engineering plant is complex you can
imagine the engineering it takes to push
a 20-ton piece of metal through the
water Wow
you know and I was personally in charge
of all the ships engineering fuel and
water that was my responsibility it's
like over three hundred and forty got
thousand gallons there's a desalination
on the ship yeah everything it's like a
floating city you know Ron that's cool I
didn't know I you you create your own
fresh water yeah
create everything what but how do you
create you just have the meal right
- eats or do you fish or oh no there's
there's a there's a there's a galley and
a kitchen and I know but when do you
bring your food with you know you fish
no they resupply you they resupply the
food every like month or how often as
necessary it can be every couple of
months if you can go up you can be a sea
for probably three months without it it
gets pretty because you count towards
the inner spinach doesn't last after for
frozen everything's frozen every dish
there's no fresh food when you're at sea
although sometimes they would stop and
they have these things called steel
Beach picnics where they would actually
you could go out and fish and fish would
follow the ships they should big fish
would follow the ships they knew they're
throwing stuff fell and and then you'd
fish and he'd catch it and cook the fish
yep that would was that was kind of rare
but yeah that that has happened and yeah
it's a little flow every every ship is
like a little floating city yeah and
there's garbage dough over the side what
do you mean over the side over the side
goes that's why that's why all the
that's why this that's why the fish know
to follow the ships
oh my [ __ ] so you could imagine [ __ ]
the planet now that this was twenty
years ago I don't know exactly what
they're doing now but if you put a ship
out at sea for three months or two
months you know there's a lot of stuff
going over the side that's just it's
been like that since the dawn of [ __ ]
yes yeah yeah well there's a big
difference between you know
biodegradable polymers and right oiled
Plaskett rolling plastics that's a big
difference so one will actually degrade
naturally no problem and then all there
will just sit there for five years 25
years so forever holy [ __ ] it learned
something new every day yeah I mean I'm
very fascinated by the sea there was a
video I watched about almost a year ago
now of it was a time-lapse of somebody
he took a time-lapse from the top of the
ship that was cruising in the water and
the time-lapse is just
gorgeous because it had Sun sunrise
sunset beautiful stars sunrise sunset
beautiful stars thunderstorm fish
jumping in the that's cool too yeah
that's it was just gorgeous so I I would
I would try and go up and enjoy as much
as possible as well I did I loved it up
there and they're like there's the sea
is it's a good metaphor a lot for life
because it can be so calming and
soothing and then the very next day just
be explosive and and like but some of
the best times there would be just this
I guess this was a form of meditation
sometimes I'd go out on the fantail
watch the sunset and that and the one of
the most beautiful things I think I've
ever seen is just a an ocean that was
completely still
as far as that I could see what there
were no waves there no waves a glass
very rare but I mean I does have I did
see that yeah so does that mostly
because there's no wind didn't know
nothing yeah
and like the ships ships the ship was
just marking time yeah so you're just
like barely going and but you know what
a experience that gave me though is the
engineering component I had down they
taught us that school but when I got
this the warfare qualification I had to
go to weapons the bridge I had to learn
navigation how to launch a missile how
to do just everything just the kitchen
how the helo operations worked and just
every app every facet of course a bad
thing
what was the sleep schedule like sleep
yeah
it varied it varied depending on your
job but for the engineering you
generally had a 5 and 10 or a 6 and 6 so
what that meant is you you you stood
watch for five hours then you were off
for five for 10 hours then you stood
watch for five it was a rotating
schedule 24/7 or you were on six and six
which meant six hours on six hours off
and then there is often a regular
workday so for the most part if you were
at sea
you you could you could definitely count
on zero sleep at some point during a
24-hour period and often times it was
not unusual for us to be awake for 24 30
40 hours at a time and then are you
sleeping on just the thin mattress pad
oh three bunks yeah three three bunks
yeah piece of steel coffin lockers is
what they call them
yeah and because if you took a missile
that was your coffin because you were
down in the below the waterline most
most of it is and 50 people to a room
holy [ __ ] the coffin lockers yeah that
is so [ __ ] up put all the beds in the
bottom so mmhmm yeah you take a missile
you have no time to get out no and so it
was it was a rough life at times but it
was also tested your limits it pushes
your limits to let you know what you're
capable of yeah and what I learned there
I mean just I was very fortunate that
they'd let me pursue this this
qualification because I learned so much
but it also allowed night it was a you
know when you're I was I was 19 at the
time 19 20 years old 20 and when I got
it and those were very formative years
for your for your you know consciousness
and it I was involved in very complex
systems in a relating with each other I
could I could probably if I figured it
out I can tell you how flushing a toilet
affects the bridge yeah or any of those
systems and and during the time I mean I
could literally on my first ship I could
bring it to a screeching halt with a cup
of salt water and some some duct tape
[Laughter]
never never would yes but I mean I under
understand systems that well and so how
that translates today is the the quantum
computing or the and the different
systems are I'm working on right now if
you were to really look at the full
spectrum of what I'm trying to develop
it's about as complex as the
interrelated systems you would find in
the combat Information Center on a
worship there are that many inputs going
into it
a desired output and so you had a little
partly in the semiconductor and the
telecom industry as well and then now
your focus on making quantum computing
to the masses really care about that
yeah that's really I mean I definitely
didn't start out like that yeah the what
you know well how did I get there I was
in the Gulf War and I came back and I
had a radio show and we'd talk about the
name of my radio show was people evolves
consciousness expands peace you know
that was about it that's about it and I
had this idea that after really
analyzing the the causation of war not
just the were in now but throughout all
of history I came to the conclusion that
peace is not achievable through
political means ever it won't be it is
in order for in order for us to achieve
peace on a large global scale it has to
become a biological imperative that
human beings need to evolve to a level
of empathy and compassion to where it's
not in their best interest to hurt
another person correct and until that
happens we will always have the conflict
resulting in this stuff and then that
that that became I thought and that's
cooled so the Gulf War led you to that
to under to wanting to get empathy and
compassion as a biological imperative
well I wouldn't say that was going on
that was definitely not going through my
mind during that period but after I got
out and had time to think about it I got
my experience in the semiconductor world
and I was looking around and and and
then when I came in in contact with this
technology
I found well here's a technology that
actually expands consciousness and if
you're expanding consciousness empathy
and compassion it's probably thrown in
there a little bit you know and so if we
can take a couple of steps forward to
actually doing that then then we can
ourselves become more
passionate and peaceful so that's what
you're doing you figured out a way to
expand consciousness yeah okay alright
so now by figuring out a way to expand
consciousness hopefully there's a larger
empathy and compassion I would say
though I figured out how consciousness
is expanded how okay that's good all
right how is consciousness expand and
that is through I would say through
neuroplasticity becomes we know what
that is a neural plasticity is really
accessing new neural pathways in your
brain and that after I got through all
the technology stuff I had to come to
realization that Wow I don't want to be
in a highly regimented system you know I
loved the semiconductor I loved the
company I worked at it was the biggest
semiconductor theorem maker I was really
good at what I did but I was just like I
have never been free and and I had to go
out and experience and something was
calling me to the arts yeah and so I got
into the arts and I actually used my
military experience while working in art
galleries I would yeah that's right you
were the director for a very large art
gallery yeah yeah okay great great
learning experience Dali some Picasso
Miro all the big big ones and we've
talked to very intelligent people
interesting high important experience in
the art and you had all this business
rapport they were building with
different people coming in the door yeah
yeah it was it was great and I was in
during this period it was just like I
wasn't in the art phase I wasn't the
technology came after that and so I was
talking to people about the nature of
reality and why art is is important to
our society and and one could even argue
why it's the most important thing it's
the only thing that matters in reality
because if you look back throughout
history to analyze societies what do we
use to do that
art the art of storytelling history and
their literal art you know if we look
back I mean if you say everything is art
then yeah
well if you look at the TV or that
everything that actually exists that
somebody made started out as an
inspirational thought yeah
and so that is things that are
manifested from the creative spirit is
what I would consider AB work of art and
there's fine art and then there's your
everyday yard you know and but I would
talk to people all day long and I came
to the conclusion while not everybody
had that epiphany experience but if you
can combine great experience with
relevant information yeah that's what a
memory is yeah yeah and that's how you
expand consciousness we can expand
consciousness through new memories new
experiences something unique and so as a
curator my my job as a curator and and
an installation artist is to create
something that nobody has ever seen
before that's the uniqueness and
nobody's ever seen before that is also
consciousness expanding well if you just
go if you if you combine a visual
something and then there's no
information that's just a visual cool
there's got to be there's got to be the
information the information is the
anchor is what's going to keep it and
sometimes if I was talking if I was
telling somebody about Picasso I would
talk to him and tell them a story about
his life that was the information that
made that the work of art more
compelling yeah you know and and so if
we can expand consciousness through that
and you know and I would say that you
know they actually taught consciousness
stuff in the Navy they taught us a lot
of that groupthink and he had a lead
groups yeah things like NLP you know all
of those things they taught us so there
was a that I had that fundamental I
didn't call it consciousness studies but
I had that thing and then I started
wondering well how do art movements
happen why do one why does one artists
who seemingly may be okay talented is
doing so much better than other artists
who seemingly don't have that much
talent why do a lot of people gravitate
and we saw this weird stuff would come
in so for example artists would come in
and put a whole series of paintings out
of
Flor and be like I don't really like
that one it gave me a lot of trouble it
was the best one of the holster
everybody in the gallery says that's the
best piece and the artist hates it you
know what is it about that
and then and people would be like
bidding on it and fighting over it and
and so like those kind of questions that
is a very interesting question when that
happens yeah why where where does that
go in there and so those questions about
how do art movements happen where that
led me into really jumping in deep into
the consciousness question and I would
say at that point is where I started
becoming a consciousness researcher so
okay so right around the time of the art
gallery that was putting some of your
principles together from your past in
the art and then also just asking these
questions about why realizing that all
of the works of inspiration that have
been built into the world are art and so
alright give me one more time so you
need information and visual to know in
spirit experience experience combined in
relevant information relevant
information and experience right Oh as
in the experience of the art of seeing
something or experience that experience
plus relevant information right because
if the relevant informations out and
it's just then it's just like kind of
like what is that there's no it's fine
casual yeah yeah yeah and then if there
is relevant information but there's no
experience then it's boring then it's
boring for the most people and this it's
so so relevant you really want to do so
if you went into if you wanted to an art
gallery and saw the description of a
work of art without the work of art most
people would not read it in it I think
in museums I think I said like most
people look the average length of a work
of art and museums like 10 less than 10
seconds yeah you know and I saw this all
the time people would walk into an art
gallery just they were just looking for
something to grab him yeah yeah and
that's what they wanted yeah exactly and
and so all of those experiences got me
thinking about the nature of reality and
particularly with art and and
you know that's also the time where I
decided you know definitely the art is
definitely my thing you know because
it's so mysterious you know there's a
there's so much that you can do with
your spirit to bring it to life with
that okay so alright
consciousness we're getting into
consciousness now why don't we can we
start with what is consciousness here's
something I learned in the Navy very
important operational definitions okay
people have different meanings for
different words mm-hm
you know they mean different things at
different people you mean like that time
right times a different difficult thing
to put definition right right or even
even thinking if you said something like
socialism if you say socialism to a
socialist and socialism to a capitalist
you're gonna get two very different
different what about like water right
maybe water is pretty fairly agreeable
on right pretty much yeah I mean like if
you want to do an operational definition
of water a liquid that contains h2o the
elements h2o that is water that powers
that body exactly powers the body were
made up but those are those are
operational definitions but if you when
you get into things that or complex
[Music]
topics and you get into like let's say
the water is consciousness in various
other words if you have a group of
people that have bring different
meanings to them then that's why I like
to make up words as well yeah describe
like zoom in a photo okay but but so
within the context of what I'm doing you
know because other people will argue
this but within the context of what I'm
doing I have a handful of operational
definitions we stick to and what are
some of them well one of those is
consciousness and that is life force it
is your life force life force your life
so it includes all of the energy from
from your body which includes all of
your thoughts your emotions your heart
the you know your heart is very
electromagnetically charged all of that
energy
everything that comes out of the body is
conscious life force life force it's a
lot so and that's why it's still applies
to animals there's consciousness to
animals just different processing right
it's a breeze if it dies it has
consciousness but then different levels
of conscious yeah yeah so okay where the
general soul of the flower has lifeforce
absolutely just less life and and
there's a consciousness component you
see if a field of daisies will track the
Sun they were attracted to that you know
that's part of consciousness and and if
you the general public they're there
their approach to consciousness is
dualistic in that they think unconscious
is either asleep or you've been knocked
out or something and the opposite of
that is consciousness and there is no
in-between yeah that's the general
perception yeah yeah but when you really
jump into it most people if well there's
a there's a conscious then there's an
unconscious self and then there's there
so like and we'll get into that but
that's how I say it is there's a there's
a conscious subconscious in it and an
unconscious and those all have different
roles and those all create a
consciousness and so because they're
bias would be a good way to understand
it right the bias like subconscious bias
versus unconscious bias you're
absolutely yes yeah so like so what
would be the subconscious bias versus
the unconscious bias the subconscious
bias well I don't know exactly what you
mean by unconscious bias unconscious
bias might not you might not even be
aware and subconscious would be like
you're aware but you still choose I
would say here's a subconscious biases
in the morning you you're you're taking
the BART to work and you walk by for
advertisements for a particular type of
gum and you walk out and really calm you
know what I feel like some gum and you
can't consciously remember seeing those
ads yeah that's a subconscious that's a
good one yeah
what about how would the unconscious
bias be related to go you're sleeping
and you're dreaming and you have a dream
that you you're you you need to call
your mom you know you dreaming about
your mom that's a subconscious driver
then you wake up in the day your you
unconscious I'm sorry you forget your
dream but you have this
resistible urge to call your mom all day
long so that would be an unconscious
driver okay okay okay cool okay so like
the dream versus the ads that's a pretty
good one okay all right all right so now
let's unpack because you said within
your consciousness research and care a
lot about how consciousness expands yeah
how we do it and it's also when I after
I did the stint at the Art Gallery did
phenomenally well there and came to the
realization that I had kind of peaked
out and I couldn't really do much more
in San Francisco and I didn't want to go
to New York and those are really the
only New York London in San Francisco
there's other art mecca's but to really
hit it that's where you got to go and I
didn't want to do that and and so I had
a you know do I start up my own gallery
and I staying at Oklahoma isn't good for
art so I was I was in this period of
rest and had ended a relationship it was
just kind of like finding myself again
you know and that's when I was
introduced to this technology and it was
through a project called the global
consciousness project and through my
studies in peace and war and and I was I
was looking at this you know I said you
know what I don't want to open up a
retail art gallery what I want to do is
I want to open up a museum dedicated to
the concept of peace I don't know how
I'm gonna do that but I'm gonna do it
good no and I started and I and then and
while I was looking through this I came
across a YouTube video about 9/11 and it
was on the global consciousness project
and how a group of networked computers
with this technology that we have right
here today are there's like 70 of these
around the earth measuring the the
consciousness of the earth 24/7 and it
was it made news during 9/11 because
they started going off the scale about
three hours before the building hit
before the first plane hit thanks okay
that's a centrally interesting that yeah
okay what are we talking about
here whatever this was originally this
technology was originally developed at
Princeton and it was with the pair labs
the Princeton anomalies research labs
Princeton anomalies research right okay
and you can still go there and so what
this does is is it this this device it
can be under under the right
circumstances this device can be subtly
affected by consciousness and if you
look here what these up sort understand
lowered deviation points are basically
calibration points where if that data
line goes outside of those that can be
attributed to some form of human
interaction that it's it's causing what
is it measuring it's literally what's
what's inside there is it's inside this
yes yes what is this
that is awesome Sylar on Sylar on is a
company that makes it but it's often
called an R eg a random event generator
or a random number generator punrng yeah
I actually don't refer to it as that
because its purpose is to detect
non-random events so I refer to it as a
non random event detector because that's
its purpose okay okay so we have a non
random event detector but that what it's
doing is just generating random numbers
data a random data
ones and zeros okay so it's randomly
generating ones and zeros but then how
would it know if there has been in
effect oh because what you seem right
there is basically the strings of ones
ones are going up zeros are going down
oh okay once okay so this fits out ones
and zeroes yeah yeah and and so then
basically what that what it's saying is
that if you flip a quarter a trillion
times you're gonna be basically 50/50
right yeah but what this shows is that
it's not they were and how this came
about is they found anomalies that it
defied the chant the odds of chance and
those periods could be correlated with
human interactions okay where they go
above or below yes is
Green and the rezard standard deviation
panas and calibrators there are
thousands of trials is that one standard
deviation up and a little down or how
many actually that I believe if I you
understand here there's actually three
in there but three deviation three so
once people so that means the the when
you go above the green or below the red
that's like in those really far into the
battle curve right exactly oh then that
means that that's in like the five
percent chance or the five percent
chance um there's actually I've got like
1 1 or less percent it's a it's
expressed in a z-score which I
calculated into odds so there's there's
a and then part part of what I want to
do is actually make this more
people-friendly yeah right so so that
doubts for gold that's for the goal of
exactly quantum computing to the masses
getting them to understand so so that so
yeah let's let's touch on this again so
how is the random zeros or ones
how can they be affected by the like on
an event like 9/11 what was that so yeah
here is this is kind of like the the
premise of my work right here and that
is answering that question because even
if you go to the pair lab and you look
at the who kind of oversees the
operations now they close down the
Princeton lab they opened up something
called the IC RL international
consciousness research lab hmm you can
go to the ICR Princeton as well
no no well it's in Princeton New Jersey
but it's not it's no longer part of the
school it was founded by the I believe
is that at the time the Dean of the
engineering department found the pair
labs they accomplished everything they
could at Princeton and they spun off
into two groups the IC RL which you can
go to IC RL org you can download tons of
white papers on this stuff too couple
dozen of them and then Seiler on which
is the commercial company that's
actually developing this stuff and so
that's patented technology silo runs the
company that makes it so the but my oh
and so when I would when I went to that
I looked at I looked at their website
and there's like there was basically an
open call for researchers like hey we
need citizen researchers because there's
still a lot of questions
this and I thought hey with my
technology background and my
understanding of systems I think I can
actually contribute some yeah and I left
the semiconductor industry because I
loved it but I didn't think I can really
contribute in a big way and I was like
wow this is really cool and I had an
experience that because the what the the
premise is pretty crazy when you think
about it or or maybe not crazy but it
definitely it's a paradigm bender
because it's saying that it's not
consciously I'm hungry I'm gonna go get
food way more calm way more complex
because it's saying that basically the
events or people's events can have an
effect on the physical world so without
any wires yeah you know and through a
field of energy through a field and so
so what Princeton most of them the group
that came out of there were really and
still are today focused on brain waves
and mind matter interaction mind matter
mind matter interaction and that's
especially important to what goes on
actually within us if you're thinking
negativity and depression and anxiety
your whole body's gonna go into that and
then if you're thinking positivity
radiating yeah yeah exactly so that's
that mind matter inside and then there's
a whole mind matter outside because if
you're being negative and you're like
this to somebody else they're gonna be
like that versus if you're happy they're
fine okay but these are inanimate
objects yeah it's not in Hanuma being
and if you look at the statistics if you
if you judge the results on this based
on a non personal bias you have to come
to the conclusion you really do have to
come to the collusion that consciousness
has an effect on it just by looking at
the because they ran hundreds and
hundreds of experiments and they had all
kinds of stuff looking at it and and so
I looked at this and came to the cushion
but I had a bias that I hadn't really
realized it at the time that after going
through the explaining this a came a few
times it came up and was when I was a
kid my brother and I were playing
hide-and-seek in the neighborhood right
and the family or the we lived in a
neighborhood with we had other family
member
aunts and uncles within short walking
distance right so it was very I grew up
in Idaho very small town so it was not
unusual for us to leave in the morning
and not come home to my stated state
stay overnight places so you know we
were out and about we're playing
hide-and-seek there was a mouse an empty
house somewhere in the neighborhood near
nearby my brother and I hiding
we were about six six seven years old we
go and we hide in an old refrigerator
one of the kids came in that there was
playing opens the door and sees us slams
the door and runs off right locks us in
we're locked in the refrigerator and
Whoopie you had closed the door how'd
you know well no we hadn't closed it all
the way enclosing no we were just hiding
in it oh geez right and they found us
and instead of yeah instead of doing
running to the tree or whatever it was
she locked the door yeah and ran away
and was just one of she didn't she
didn't know it what she was gonna play
in a game right and and my brother were
in there can't get out airtight you know
Wow we're like struggling breathing airs
getting it's getting hot were screaming
we don't know what's going on my mother
down the street she's at home doing
something and she just has a panic
attack for absolutely no reason she said
there's something wrong with my babies
that's what going went through her head
she runs out of the house screaming our
names nobody answered nobody said
anything she does a beeline she just
sees that house and she runs right to
the house runs into the kitchen now she
doesn't hear us if you were standing in
the next room you probably couldn't have
heard of screaming cuz there's no way
she heard us a half a block no way no
way no way and she opens the door and
both of our bodies fall out but
something about what was going on that
is ethereal exactly what's happening so
so that so I so that that was very real
we opened up I mean this was the
childhood story that we grew up we
almost died you know I think the
ambulance was called they brought us
together and if five more minutes we
would have been gone
you know and so I grew up with the
notion that we are connected somehow
yeah yeah in and I've gone through and
looked at actually this is a crazy story
I found lots of other stories like that
including definitely I've heard of
another story oh yeah what's his name
Elmer the inventor of EEG had a similar
story the reason why he was convinced
brain waves had to them because he had a
near-death experience and his sister was
like what's wrong what's wrong and he's
like how did she know she's in a
different country and that's what's
burned off eg it was one of those
experiences and those those happen so
like I look to that say okay there's
there's there's a connection I don't
know what it is and I personally don't
buy into the psychic oh yeah there was
that other one about the test that was
taken in the UK and Australia I wish I
remembered this more but it was that the
it was something about the people
scoring a better result after the other
country scored a better result
themselves just something along those
lines and they didn't have any
information about the test that which I
knew that was better but stuff like that
also if you know being able to really
feel what it feels like to to not have
access to clean water or food across the
world yeah or or to be suffering in some
other sort of way or to have previously
potentially you know thought about what
it would have been like - where were you
prior to be - being made within your
mother and where were you after you died
you know where what was going on before
those moments and yeah yeah we're all
very interesting there she's kind of
between there's somewhat something about
this mind matter connection that is
deeply surreal yeah yes Ron again but
that's interesting to ponder that you
know yeah we know personally though I'm
sorry well well let's continue unpacking
that's a great story so now where do
so when I came across this as like okay
well there is a there's a connection
somewhere we are connected somehow
I don't understand how and this is an
open door to explore that and so I
looked at this I'm like well you know no
scientists nobody's gonna know
materialist is gonna tell me that my
mother was an accident
that that was an accident that it was a
coincidence or something you know
there's too many of the stories so so
but at the same time I'm also a very
pragmatic yeah science-based person I'm
not a spiritual practitioner and the I
mean I'm meditating stuff but I've never
been into the woowoo component but
woowoo changes with the times you know I
was laughs so so so I started what the
first thing I did it I just bought the
stuff I got the kids and I started I'm
gonna find this stuff found myself
Robster silence Sylar wrong right right
and so I got I got a kid too got stuff
and I started doing experiments myself
today I've done today I've done over 400
and timed experiments and more than a
dozen like being like World's Fair nano
or Burning Man or a pre-compression I've
done pre-compression twice World's Fair
Maker Faire you know we won two Editors
Choice Awards last year great and so so
we're definitely onto something but when
I didn't start out with that at all it
was simply answering these questions
about but I made I did make a conscious
choice right from the beginning to take
a radically different approach than all
of the other research that was going on
because all the other research and you
will find this in the papers and I think
I've read them all but they were all
focused on proving in many ways the same
thing over and over again but proving
that mine brain has an effect on these
things has hasn't that it affects them
has and effects them at the brain
affects your thoughts affect this
correct you got something you did
different I took a very different
approach
and my approach was because I think they
already proved that consciousness has an
effect I don't think it's purely
brainwaves but a lot of people think
that but I approaches to with my system
engineering experience I was like well I
want to know why this behaves the way it
does which is a radically different
question than proving a point I wanted
to explain why this behave if I with the
premise that if consciousness has an
effect on it yes why does it behave the
way it does why is it so random and why
can't it be better controlled those kind
of questions
yes that's what I set out and what have
been I've achieved yes so we go into
these posters we can go into the posters
okay and for the viewers you can go to
academia.edu Willingham bio academia.edu
yeah and it's the edge of aztlán tracer
and spatial relativity and so I had a
radio show when I started I started a
radio show called scream for peace and
my objective was I'm this is gonna be
the catalyst to open up a museum
dedicated to this stuff and so I'm gonna
start talking about this on the radio
and and so I still have all the podcasts
they can didn't go to scream for peace
and still listen to him someone pretty
wild you know but it was philosophy art
and science and it wasn't just about
this but we were running experiments and
we had a lot of stuff going on and and
but I was trying to explain complex
theories over the radio without any real
visuals yeah so I was coming up with
these metaphors and and some of them
after one in particularly I would I
would talk about science stuff and then
I would talk about a lot of the faults
science that's out there and how we
often if you look out throughout history
the the dogmatic institutional
organizations that dictate what is real
are almost always discovered to be wrong
yeah you know so you have to look at
today and say what do we accept today as
true as it was at you know soon will be
found
discovered to be wrong and so because I
wasn't part of the establishment and I
was
an independent researcher I didn't have
any restrictions on what I could say or
thinker which is great which is really I
mean there was nobody who's paying me to
do correct correct as the same thing
that we're going through right now
exactly exactly so if there was if there
was value to what I was doing I would
find value in it okay I came to some
realization like wow these metaphors
that I'm using are related they're
really actually makes sense and so I
started delving into it further and I
came to some some some I guess you'd
call rebel epiphanies so let's let's but
as as we go in there can we also so over
400 consciousness researchers are saying
that my brainwaves or my consciousness
effects that Sylar on which is a random
number generator right but why do you
call it a quantum computer okay because
it's a solid-state processor there the
computes data and the data emanates from
a quantum source which is called
electron tunneling and actually
wikipedia has a very good does our intel
i7 chip use quantum time no not like
this no and this is different because
that the regular computers use some form
of tunneling through I think what is it
Fe T's right but this is different in
that this has an electron emitter and a
negatively charged barrier potential
barrier right so according to the rules
of classical physics
if you shoot an electron towards a
negatively charged barrier what's it
supposed to do you got - it should be L
not so if you if you if you delve into a
lot of the you know here's so much these
days but you know about ten years ago
you heard this a lot and what you're
saying that teleportation that doesn't
happen oh it does repel most of them oh
but every once in a while one slips
through this was this was back in the
70s it was really a big big things like
how does that slip through it's not
supposed to do that that is against the
laws of fishing that's
electron tunneling yes and so with that
there's a phenomenon - exactly
yes and so so it's not qubit processing
but it's quantum because the data source
emanates so it's a non-deterministic
data source that emanates from a quantum
function so what happens is this
electron shoots at it probably about a
thousand times a second and it's
calibrated now they have a calibration
to where it actually penetrates it about
200 times a second 200 times a second
and so a way so when the electron goes
through it if it changes state its
translated to a zero and if it doesn't
change today it's translated to 1 and
those dreams of ones and zeros are often
correlated with real work after you and
I've seen it without a doubt that that
is and then and so how is my either
positivity or negativity or whatever
affecting fast so let's get it can we
get into this because this is what that
will explain yeah ok so let's just hold
further should we do the center camera
ok so so this is so these are posters
that were created I was invited to do an
installation and be a presenter at the
science and non-duality conference we
were there 2015 and 2016 skipped last
year but for the poster session these
are the posters we created for that and
I had an academic challenge app which
still stands today if anybody and I
would invite anybody watching this
anybody can invalidate what my findings
are because if I'm wrong yeah I want to
be the first to know yeah yeah and in
general that's the interesting premise
of the difficult sciences it's it's hard
to prove people wrong right all right it
takes a lot of time and resources and
yes what I and I don't even and I'm not
even talking about like if somebody has
a sincere hey I have something to add
definitely I want to know about yeah
yeah you know it's easy to throw rocks
right let's see so so my academic
challenge though is I will give anybody
anything that I own if they can
invalidate my premise your heart
anything I know well I
so this is just we I don't know if we
have this is actually a poem that
describes the whole thing and then and
then it's just the outline the big thing
so this is actually designed to be about
a one to two hour presentation when I
build it out and this will be the
premise of a white paper that I will
submit I've got a couple more big
experiments to do but these are some of
the primary components that come into
effect on the effect of this we have to
understand that so the idea of spatial
distortion which also has to do with
relativity if you have a spatial
distortion you have a time distortion
space in time I look at how we'll say
this is is like the earth curving
space-time I think you think of think of
time most people think of time as a line
right and I think of it some people a
coin you can think of it Queen or think
of it as a razor blade where you have
you have special relativity on one side
general relativity other than the other
in the edge is spatial relativity so
that'll come in but these are the things
some molecule displacement you know if
my hand is here its de space and it's
displacing the air yeah and the time
right it's displacing time as well it is
how is it displacing the time because we
live in everything is about time time
time and space are to the sides of the
same coin but my hand is the spaceman is
spaced right so there's gonna be a
warping around it they're ever so
settled over so so okay and and so you
have cominging your spatial distortion
molecule to space right and then when
you bring those together you have
cominging
so we see this a lot in thermodynamics
particularly this but think of these
primary concepts and so here in
relativity so so one of the things I
started looking at when I was on the
radio is like let's like it's particular
to some of the guess I had let's take
the concept of
speculative science and put it in the
speculative category and not discuss
that when we're discussing this because
what we're talking about here is
something that can be tested and we're
not talking about radical theories right
so but we do address that yeah but yeah
let's go with as much of the objective
yes yeah it's possible so this is also
so a lot of people that don't have the
science background I'll talk a little
bit about double slit experiments do it
and so this the first double slit
experiment occurred about 200 years ago
with young and it was the experiment
that showed the dualistic nature of time
and might
I'm sorry not polite the dualistic
nature of light that it's both a
particle and a wave you have the
interference pattern there but there's
also a component of retro causation
coming out there because it's a 200 year
old experiment it still can't be fully
explained
so for exists our best explanation of it
what's our best explanation I think that
is still the best explanation it hasn't
been accepted right like light goes
through a single slit and then through
two slits right so this would be the the
light source coming through here and the
explanation is that the electrons are
actually going through both slits at the
same time that's that's what these two
oh right right that's how you get the
interference pattern that's that's why
there's three appearances of whitens
yeah this is just an example of what
they say that the electron managed to go
through both everything all at the same
time right and and and but getting
getting the the when they measure it how
they measure it is actually one of the
things about it I think that was very
was the observation effect that just the
idea of measuring something will change
it so think about the observer effect
there with with that functioning and
then here are some other theories that
came out in theory in the multiple
dimensions so a lot of times when you
hear I set this down yeah when you hear
discussions about multiple dimensions
for me my hair stands
I'm just like yeah sing with Ron and I
we yeah we talked a little bit about
what that ethereal life is outside of a
3d world yeah yeah so so when when I
heard that again I'm thinking okay what
could be another explanation for the
multiple dimensions because I don't buy
that there's another me out there I
think there are multiple universes I
think there are an infinite number of
galaxies and life-forms out there
somewhere but the fact that do you know
absolutely that's just that's just
saying a different word at this time
yeah there's no other there's no other
me out there because I think that that's
just your opinion
huh that's just you know I can prove
that there's no other I can I cannot
prove that there's a not and if it world
but I can prove that I'm a unique
individual because there's no other one
there other me and that's where the
speculative part comes in that I don't I
don't get into because that's that's an
argument it's like the straw argument
you could just argue it to argue it
right I am just very just quickly
fascinated by it though because I'm
fascinated too but that goes into the
world of speculation speculation yeah
yeah so so my thing well I don't you
really people can speculate all the time
but that what that is it's faith and
belief in science that doesn't exist
which is religion as far as I'm
concerned we don't need to tag it well
when I look at faith and belief in
something that can't be proven or
conversation about something that cannot
yet be proven can be inspirational all
right there you go so let's end it on
that and then I love sci-fi I write
about this stuff yeah right but for the
purposes of this I approached it it's
like what could be another rational
explanation that could be proof that
could be proven today I'm just surprised
that you say that there's infinite
amount of galaxies but that an infinite
amount of life forms but that you don't
think that there is then potential to
have another okay all right let's do it
let's keep moving along
is the what you were just describing so
this this sort of explains it the
wavefunction how it goes through the
potential barrier and then measured on
the other side yeah okay and I like to
talk I'm not I'm not a that's one of the
reasons why I left micron is I'm not a
computer scientist I do know how to make
semiconductors so and this this this
whole apparatus it's just it is a
solid-state processing unit and I think
for okay so the electron shoots there
what it's actually doing what my theory
and I will get Illustrated is is
detecting spatial distortions at the
electron that will create it by waves of
consciousness it's one more time repeat
alas it's creating or it's detecting
spatial distortions visual distortions
at the electron level yeah
created by waves of consciousness and
I'll get into how waves of consciousness
are created okay okay let's basically
what it does okay and now remember
consciousness is your whole life or
force and so the dimensions and looking
at this so keep it so these were some
these are the the premise I have you
know Occam's razor
yeah Occam's razor the simplest
explanation is usually the best yes you
should I start there you should start
right there yeah right simply so that's
what what what my actual thing is it's a
it's a very it's elegant and simple when
you really look at it and I think that's
why some people have a very difficult
time with it because it is simple but
okay okay using that I approached this
this is has more to do with the multiple
dimensions we'll get into that and but
this in particular always earth me and
that was the twin paradox when one goes
into space yes right so let's just well
it's not just space but they pull of
space-time well the paradox is that if
you put
human being on earth and another twin on
a spaceship and they travel through the
speed of light that time is going to
they're not going to age the same and so
this was this was really made very
popular in a recent movie called the
what's the it was think of Matthew
McConaughey oh yeah I know which one
you're talking interstellar was
interstellar where the the daughter
grows older than her son their then her
father and all that and and I'm looking
at that so this is where we have to take
the speculation stuff and put it out so
for one thing the reason why light
travels at the speed it does because it
has no mass and if you if you look at
even the math of the math proves you
can't travel the speed of light humans
can and there's never been one hasn't no
math no no I'm saying that you couldn't
build anything light travels the way it
does because it does not have mass it's
a massless photons have no mass no mass
no mass there yeah it's a massless wave
packet of energy it's actually what it
is
and so anything with mass people are not
going to ever travel if SB can't so I
take the entire notion of life speed
travel and put it in the speculation
point and say that this that that whole
premise comes through a misunderstanding
of this this is the formula for time
right and so people say that that as the
velocity reaches the speed of light time
will stop because one minus one is zero
and therefore if you travel faster than
the speed of light it's gonna go
backwards yeah and so that to me is just
scientific hyperbole and a
misunderstanding of what this means it's
this actually says that time is
dualistic in nature there's there's a
there's an absolute time and then
there's a relative time depending on
where you're at in which things are
being compared and that that's what we
have here so so an absolute time would
be like the life stars the life time of
the cosmos yes and then the relative
time would be if we are traveling how
beings measure that and then also if
we're traveling at half the speed of
light somewhere then that's also
relative well
I think I think you could talk about
things traveling at or near the speed of
light as long as you're not talking
about people people radio waves or white
other source of light sure ok you can
and so what you see what yes so you're
saying the non-dualistic or that you are
to sing to do lists there's actually a
this shows that there's a dualistic
nature at a time yeah and that that you
cannot take one without the other they
always have to be and and that's when
you agree yeah yeah and so but but we're
popular culture I think it's
misrepresenting science and it very well
there's a if you go to youtube right now
and look at the sign just do a search of
relativity you're gonna find dozens of
really super amazing videos they're put
together on relativity but they they
about halfway through they will
disembark from reality and embark on
fantasy yeah can not make the
distinction because they are telling
people that this is the way the universe
looks at the speed of light if you were
to travel speed or time travel as
possible all we have to do is a complete
rubbish all of that aspect of it is just
scientific like I said fantasy so that
so part of the part of what we're doing
also when that's why I call it spatial
relativity is we're going to add another
component to this and show how our
consciousness effects time ah ok yes and
how how that works so what's your
equation that involves consciousness
yeah I know I'm not omniscient and this
is where they're actually looking for
collaborators particularly
mathematicians to map out and
and new numeric if I my the mob
consciousness effects time yes yes yes
and just by this device right here we
already know that it does and so we have
this now back to the multiple dimensions
we take this this is another explanation
for that so if the mathematics if you
delve into a lot of the mathematics
equate am in the mentioned there's
seemingly an infinite number of
dimensions and here's a great great
quote I'm gonna read it if it's okay
yeah
dimensions are simply the different
facets of what we perceive to be reality
we are immediately aware of the three
dimensions that surround us on a daily
basis those that define the length width
and depth depth of all objects in our
universe the x y&z axis is specifically
beyond these three visible dimensions
scientists believe that there may be
many more in fact the theoretical
framework of superstring theory posits
that the universe exists in ten
different dimensions these ten aspects
are what govern the universe the
fundamental facets of nature and all the
elementary particles contained within
Matt Williams universe today yeah all
right so there is already a tremendous
amount of research the shows that
there's I mean we kind of live in a
base-10 system you know you can say that
mathematics is not an invention of
people mathematics is our numeric our
symbology to understand the universe and
describe what we're seeing with numbers
so I started thinking about how would
that wait a minute what is through do we
really live in three dimensions three
dimensions describe height depth of
width but when you look around you you
are more than height depth and width you
have all kinds you couldn't point to
height depth and width to describe
anything right you could describe their
place in regards to other things but it
doesn't describe anything and so I
thought well what if these multiple
dimensions are actually all around us
and we see them and interact with them
what if the multiple dimensions because
the word dimensions we're all programmed
by sci-fi all of us if you're if you're
a person interested in science in
America or anywhere in the world today
with the internet your first
introduction is science fiction
Star Trek movies all this stuff so we
get taught all the fantasy stuff first
the more complex so when we go into when
we hear the word dimension multiple
dimensions we think of a phase shift in
reality where you can teleport to some
other unknown world right and I thought
well okay that's that that's that's put
that in the speculation category and
let's just think about what else it
could mean with what we have to work
with and my thoughts well the it's a
spatial if you if you are a human miss
was like you are you're surrounded by
all kinds of things right and so I came
up with this model and it works well but
here our conscious for consciousness so
on a three-dimensional reality this is
often looked at this is this it's like
the bug on the bug on the rod if you
were a bug on this rod it would look
like a 2-dimensional reality right from
us it looks like a three-dimensional now
but if you were like a microbe the bugs
leg it would just look like oh we would
look fact and then and so if to the
micron small thing on the bugs leg we
would be the fourth dimension and in in
and say so it really depends on the
perspective so I started thinking about
what would be the fourth two men from my
giving if there was a - a bug on a pole
the bug lands on the pole the bug sees
that the pole is flat right and it
thinks that it's in a 2d well to us it's
2d to hit it's 3d because that bug is
gonna see the edge it's gonna see that's
gonna say can see little fun to that
bugs 3d 3d but to us
they experience a 2d world because
they're just
to see that we can explain that to them
right to us but I would put to them to
us it looks like they're experiencing a
2d well that's how it's often explained
yeah yeah it's just like for us in the
3d world we get height depth and width
but if you were to look at this little
bug in there and say well they can only
see backwards before they don't see
everything we see they don't see us out
there they're living in a 2d world but
then if there was something small on
that bug's leg then they would see
something really different and to them
that would be everything would have
dimension you know so it depends on the
perspective that you're looking at and
so I think that that fundamental premise
right there is where the mathematicians
looked at 10 dimensions where are we
going to get 10 dimensions where's that
there must be these unseen spaces that
lead to alternate universes in realities
because that word dimension has a lot of
different meanings so operational so
here's here's here's go back to this one
and talk about dimensions so if you look
this is the pizza pie we we let's I know
that we want to get to as much of this
as possible so we we will let's let's
let's go through the main key points
well as much as we can yeah this is so
the multiple dimensions if you if you
took a pizza pie right and slice it in
10 equal pieces you would have 10
dimensions seemingly similar very
similar of the same thing but they would
all be different right so we know those
are 10 dimensions take that same concept
that expand that out to a sphere if you
were to take that sphere and carve it
into 10 equal things you would have 10
cone yeah shades with the center point
yeah 10 dimensions seemingly the same
right but if you were to take a knife
and start carving up those dimensions
down to the Planck length how many could
you carve a seemingly infinite number
right okay you could cut that up in many
different ways because I seem to be
equal but they're not they're similar
like if you were to take ten spheres how
could you help
Jew how could you take or the ten cones
and one of these how could you take one
sphere one cone and differentiate it
from the other if your center point was
right all look exactly the same but from
that center point you would have ten
dimensions of reality surrounding it
okay so so this is supported right not
just by back to you so is this saying
that at every single Planck length that
there is the ten yeah you could you
could draw ten vector points from every
any point why can't you draw an infinite
okay well you couldn't draw an infinite
number because ya plank you could draw
as many Co from a plank to a plank right
plankton plane
yeah you can do but and you can do that
with all of mathematics but why do we
live in a base-10 system so somewhere
you got to draw a line so cuz otherwise
we would yeah you did almost everything
yeah yeah and it seems like him so like
Zeno you know about so you keep walking
to the wall right and just take a half
so this is my non math resolve of that
you know overall distance every step
down to the Planck length when you get
to the Planck length there's no further
you can go we know that
listen let me keep going Planck at a
time when you eventually get one until
you get to one Planck length then you
got to get down to zero so you have to
draw the line so so so yeah so
eventually you go if I'm trying to watch
at the wall half half half half half
half down the plank once I get to plank
then I can go point clean point please
don't tell you though well you can't
take it plank in half plank you're not a
plank in half yeah I never said plank in
half I'm saying plank then another plank
and then oh well when you get down to
here if you were if you're gonna be
crazy would break down because there
would be no halves right there's no half
you can't point half so then the Zeno
paradox still stays stands no this would
solve it because it would you would get
down you would take a half step half
distance until you got down to one plank
that's as far as you could go you would
have to that would be the end yeah but
you're still not at the wall so he's
thrown it solved it
well if the wall is what you solving it
okay all right so so so interesting
every single plank can go plank around
it would think about take it out of the
abstract and think about yourself yeah
where is it let's just say your center
points right there sure sure
somewhere in there yeah outside of you
are you just three dimensions well
here's a good way I think to explain it
maybe it's rather than the plank think
about it like the atoms in the air there
is one let's say oxygen atom right here
and then around it are and basically
almost an infinite but close to the
amount of oxygen the oxygen or nitrogen
atoms that can then be around it and
then next to that next atom is the same
thing right it's going on so that's a
that's kind of a I think a decent way to
understand maybe your cells are another
decent way to understand it's like your
cell and then another wherever you look
in whichever way is another cell
whichever way is gonna be something else
out if you're in the physical world and
so what this says is like we have our
own personal zero-point and we're
surrounded by ten dimensions of reality
there's no gap in anything there's no
gaps there's no gaps and remember you
are everything's filled equals
mc-squared right well what if E is me
what if I me what is my energy and how
is that how does that emanate what if me
yeah so what if the energy is me so now
how am i acting the atoms and so this
mass times the speed of light squared U
is y times the speed of light squared is
your is your energy now that's a pretty
radical thing to think about it our
connection to the universe
yeah is how does that exactly work well
what does that end up being the mass is
measured in grams there well no I mean
you would have to I I haven't actually
measured all of it out but you would
have to take the power of the heart your
heart beats the the power of it's much
weaker up here but you'd have to take
the whole thing and that that's actually
we're all for mass huh for mass yeah
though it's not just kilograms oh it's
no no that's some people say that but
your mass would also be the energy that
your heart is emanating and beating out
so and then you'd multiply that times
300 million three beats meters per
second 300 million miles per second oh
the speed of light yeah yeah yeah 299 so
what is what is your what would that
come to your energy would just be
massive then basically we are massive
yeah yeah so just think about that for a
second without breaking it down into an
actual formulation so we are mad your
heart has been beating since before you
were born
yeah yeah here's another here's another
thing that I had I had approached in
that the phenomenon that we exist
Erick's unexplainable phenomenons that
we all exist a kidney that can sometimes
just be attributed to chance or
coincidence but here's one the the that
I think requires and I think I've got it
here requires an explanation that is the
idea that is somebody that you're
entangled to and you maybe maybe it's
somebody you haven't talked to in a long
time and then for some reason you just
start thinking about him yeah
and then you're like whoa you know
something I need to really call Mary
yeah and then all of a sudden Mary calls
you and you haven't talked to Mary in
months you're like wow I just was
thinking about you so weird that you
call so what all the times it doesn't
happen though I know I know so so so
yeah you think about people all the time
too but when you compare that experience
to what I had said before the experience
with the mom and things like that it's
very similar sure yeah yeah so so even
if even if it was coincidence they're
words coincidence doesn't explain I'm
just saying if your mom went away
to that house and open the fridge yeah
exactly so so there are situations like
that that occur all the time yeah yeah
so but that that that that that
occurrence I'd realized over time that
that it's not something that happens to
some people once in a while like I
originally thought it happens to most
people on a pretty regular basis and
that's like okay well what's the
mechanism for that how is that working
why is it that people can do this to
somebody that's halfway across or are
people just looking at that math and
thinking that oh great it happened it
relates to me and then whenever it
doesn't relate to them or the math
doesn't work I get it you forget it
right right and I think that that that's
that's something that can always be
throw it out there but this is actually
an explanation all right so let's see so
there's a toroidal shape around each
human each human yeah right and that's a
very Kundalini thing as well in the East
that there's this there's this center
pole of energy going up and down your
spine through your brain and how your
pelvis and and that you're just a
freaking beast of energy just going and
we are I mean I mean by today's a
hundred years ago this would be
considered theory but the stuff heart
math is doing and other organizations
it's it's a it's a fact that your heart
is a very powerful huge huge huge power
and even with the rudimentary tools of
today they can measure it 1215 feet away
or something like that so my my model
includes that every once your heart
started beating what you're doing is
prime and this actually came through I
worked with sonar and radar in the in
the Navy and you have even with
transmission you have radio waves
carrier waves right carrier waves haves
a message impacted into a stronger wave
that goes to let's say a radio through a
transubstantiation process and that is
basically decoded and the sound comes
out right so my heart and B so think
yeah think about this your heart's been
beating since before you're born and it
just take that first heartbeat goes this
far second heartbeat a little bit
further
third heartbeat just think about what
waves and then eventually once you're an
adult and yes it's pretty good you have
a proof well you have a pretty oh you're
saying that your heartbeat would go
never stop but it would go out in
space-time as far as poss right here all
the way around the world it's going to
propagate now this is where I have to
math it out with some help but if we
could measure the distance of the heart
measure how many heartbeats you've been
and in you know yeah we can measure that
yeah and so you're each each time it you
you beat how would it go around the
earth when to just go out well there is
no word how yeah you mean straight let's
just say but it's going to it's going to
be in every direction every direction
yeah right and but then we have an
atmosphere and things is probably going
to keep it low but let just think about
it just continuously continuously going
and happening for every human yes every
human okay it's going and every animal
and every animal and every living thing
yeah so part of our atmosphere this is
where I come up with the phrase ether
sphere okay so in this one was
interesting to us yes these two actually
go together very well
yeah okay so you can see that if we
propagate the world you know with that
energy and we can I could show that how
to do that mathematically and then when
we interact with each other as well you
ever meet somebody just like right away
that you just painted them right away or
that you love them you know or the other
way but oftentimes those first
impressions after you begin modulating
with them go away you know and those can
be reversed or sometimes you just meet
somebody and you just you know what I'm
with them we totally get each other yeah
we just had that with Lisa on the last
on the last cast we just went into
straight love and it was amazing the
first vote yesterday so so so these two
work together to explain those things so
think about this for a second every when
your heart beats now there's proof we
know that there are neurons
the travel from the head to the heart
yeah you had the vagueness vagus nerves
is part of it because I think there's
there's separate neural pathways that go
from the head to the heart yeah right so
imagine this for a second when your
heart beats it's actually taking a
snapshot of your psyche basically and
encoding that Oh interest in - it's like
a carrier wave into the heart the heart
is what carries that out oh you know
rather than the brain rather than the
brain yeah because the brain's not
strong enough to trim this is to emanate
this is where I think a lot of the a lot
of the research those the brain doesn't
do a pulse no the heart is a home I'm
just constantly going exactly and
comparatively speaking this is much
weaker electro the electro-charged their
assurance so so a lot of the research
that's been based on this has been
trying to prove something that this
affects that yeah and that's where so so
imagine we're let's get back to this for
a second so you have there's a
collective consciousness yeah right
yeah there's you ever see birds swarm or
fish swarm yeah that's called
murmuration yeah people do it too that's
the foundation of sports teamwork you
can see it mirror mirror neurons yeah a
little bit different I mean that's what
has definitely has something to do with
it so this this sort of so so let's say
in your brain you I'm just gonna pick
out a name Suzy who lives in Wisconsin
is a really good friend of yours and you
know that her birthday's coming up and
you're like uh what should I get I'm
gonna I haven't talked in a while and I
want to go out and see her what's
happening is every time your heart beats
your combination sending sending a
message out to Suzy who's you know over
here yeah and since her heart has also
been beating since before she was born
and her ether sphere envelops the earth
as well there's a lot of beats that are
going on so how does it how Suzy and
Alan's hearts know too because you're
already entangled you're already
intended with everyone else's anyways no
it's gonna be it'll be think of the but
whatever is being encoded but whatever
is being encoded it that's out there so
so even though there are seven and a
half billion people plus all of these
animals and
living things beating and creating a
collective consciousness the yours
whatever message is being encoded by you
at that time is being propagated out so
then then that even though there is this
collective consciousness this hive mind
going on that beat has a specific
message encoded in it and that way it
can be entangled with the other message
that's encoded would potentially with
somebody else that's thinking about it
at the same time that maybe they're not
thinking about it at the same time dude
where did that how does that entangle
then if you if you have a thought about
somebody where did that thought come
from could it be because of them no it
could be so okay alright let's um it
could be yeah that's fascinating stuff I
totally agree can we can we safely say
we covered like a good amount of let's
summarize let's summarize
okay so let's summarize let me try and
summarize okay okay I'll try and
summarize so we have a we have the way
that consciousness expands is the thing
that we're researching and trying to
understand and the probably one of the
most recent towards the tail-end that I
thought was really fascinating was that
whatever the brain is thinking at the
time is encoded into the heart and the
heart beats it out electromagnetically
through the world okay and then that
affects things like that electron
tunneling and then we can have a better
understanding of what exactly is going
on with this collective consciousness
with heart hearts inter playing with
your with your what if E is me so and
this this discusses again from the
beginning how our consciousness affects
the material plane so so that that unit
right there I like to think of it as a
buoy rather than a like a detector of
a temperature gauge or something it's
more like a buoy and we're in a sea of
consciousness like an ocean of
consciousness so if you can imagine a
buoy sitting in the middle of a swimming
pool yeah and it's surrounded by people
and everybody jumps in at the same time
yeah
who's gonna have a biggest effect on it
you don't know a lot of those waves are
gonna cancel each other out they're
gonna bounce off each other if two
people happen to jump in at the same
time their waves might combine and make
a really big wave but all the other ones
are still happens to get an allergy so
this is why this behaves the way it does
is because well a it's not being a
controlled by our brain it's being
affected by every heartbeat around but
with our intention now this is part of
the I'd still have to some work on this
but with our intention we can direct the
power of that heart signal so let's say
your signals going out it's going out
there's a lot of people right now you're
not thinking about right but the moment
you start thinking about that person or
that thing it's like a almost like a
guidance system where that you're that
signal that's coming out it's gonna be
directed to that particularly if you're
looking at it yeah yeah because that's
encoding so much more when you're
looking at exactly and there's there's
people in security know this that if you
if somebody is doing something you don't
like just stare at them that's the first
thing they do is just stare at it it
doesn't feel uncomfortable because you
can tell you can't always tell but you
can sometimes tell when you're being
looked at that's a good analogy to write
because especially when you're passing
your glance and then you see the
security are staring at you're like what
the [ __ ] am i doing yeah so so I think
that I really have solved the the the
the mystery of why that behaves the way
it does
and why they get reading sometimes not
others you know this this model that
I've just verbally explain to you
explains all of that and and so this is
really a component of it which kind of
was where I set out to do it but when I
started putting into practice it really
evolved into something much bigger with
the pyramid and
in the installations and doing that and
that's and that's for an on-site trip at
a later time together I mean the cameras
there and not explicitly explained like
what we're talking about yeah spice it
in with some sure sure well we will
throw some links in the bio
I think the first time I went through
your what do you call experience the
Azoff pyramid a South pyramid the Azoth
pyramid was I think like two almost two
years two and a half years ago something
like that at the mary's event and at the
oakland commons yeah yeah yeah it was
like a biohacking event it was really
cool but I knew you before then we did I
think wait where do we know where we met
but I you invited me to go to your show
the comedy show yeah yeah that's where
we might have met online yeah yeah we
have Facebook and stuff but but so then
we did the the ESL pyramid and so the
the the the essence of of putting on the
so let me see if I can get this right so
I put on on something that a glass is
that that that blocked the the
perception of of what you see in the
outside world and you're limited to what
you've put on the glasses and what
you've put on the glasses are is it led
the LED lights and then you have a
specific wave way of of entraining
the consciousness and it's similar to a
meditative state similar like if you if
you stare at a campfire if you've been
out camping yeah kinda get in trance
East you do yeah that isn't treatment
yeah so it's a meditative state
brainwaves go from being staticky to
more smoothly and so how that came about
though it is it is the experiment is one
of these so so I would I'd say okay
because a lot of the research is
affecting one of these and I wasn't
interested in controlled experiments
because I thought they achieved
everything they needed to achieve in the
controlled and I was really interested
how does this work in the world world
what utility can we find from this and
and where where can i how can i affect
this the most and i thought well if
there's a non-local
back to it there's obviously got to be a
local effect to of it as well and I
tried I took it to various events at the
beginning and then I came to the
conclusion the best opportunity the best
opportunity to do this was art events
and it was because art events provide a
wonderful
that's bad for the other right and so I
thought well if I really wanted so my
part of my hypothesis was if this if
this thing works the way I think it does
an entanglement in the conventional
scientific bonding method or common app
understanding of entanglement works then
we should over the course of an event we
should have a trend of some sort because
yeah what would happen is people would
come in and experience it they get
entangled to it and then they leave but
they're still entangled to it why
because we gave them a wonderful weird
experience and then we combined it with
information yeah this is what we're
doing this is and that's exactly why
these you're everything from the a cell
pyramid all the way to you know our live
events that we host as well we do
experiments that have experiences that
have information yes
yeah it's meaningful yeah and then so I
have these and I have a couple of
inventions one in particular is this
technology hooked up to ten lights and
and being able to visually see being
able to visually see this data in action
in color and so we would go to these
events for the for the purpose and it
works and it works
Ron is it okay if we close out now can
we do let's close out all right so that
was solid we've covered a lot of ground
will will have to do another part where
we actually get even deeper into all
this and we'll also run you through some
of the simulation questions well thanks
so much yeah thanks this is such a
pleasure do you got links in the bio
everyone thanks for tuning in if you
guys had a good time definitely give us
a like comment subscribe we'd love to
hear from you leo would love to hear
from you this is really interesting
expanding stuff it's just it's really
it's clean you know it takes a while to
understand but it's it's it's a complex
theory with lots of interrelationships
but when you really look at it thrown
out it's quite simple and elegant yeah
yeah and it'll still take more time
human humans are you know we're just
monkeys on the rock it says so alright
like comment subscribe check out the
links in the bio and thanks for tuning
in everyone will be actually soon peace
Roman can you hear Allen Roman can you
hear me yes okay great okay excellent